matt reeves director and co-writer of
the batman may be about to experience
his greatest success to date as the film
delivers justice to the box office a
character like the caped crusader can be
difficult to translate to the screen and
there are more than a few examples of it
not going well however reeves has a rich
history of elevating mainstream
blockbusters into something more than
the sum of their parts audiences didn't
need much convincing to watch the
director's planet of the apes movies the
promise of seeing monkeys toting machine
guns on horseback was more than enough
to draw a crowd but reeves nonetheless
transformed the material into a sweeping
commentary on the nature of humanity
itself though not without its detractors
early reviews of the batman suggests
reeves has once again pulled off that
trick with critics praising its
ambitious storytelling and surprising
cast perhaps the most eyebrow raising
choice reeves made was his early
decision to place robert pattinson under
the cowl as the titular hero himself a
decision he made after watching the
actor's performance in the harrowing
safety brothers crime thriller good time
but that belief in his star appears to
have paid off as pattinson has reflected
fondly on their working relationship in
interviews asked by rotten tomatoes
about reeves on-set instruction
pattinson reaffirmed his trust in the
director and the rapport they built
while filming the batman when you felt
it matt always felt it and so it's kind
of it was a it was a kind of uh
unspoken language that we developed
quite quickly the actor also explained
that he doesn't always know what his
performances will be like because he
relies on an immersive acting style
telling rotten tomatoes once you get
onto his rhythm you can kind of feel
because i'm kind of quite intuitive
about what i'm doing it's a roll of the
dice every take i don't really have that
much control over it luckily matt reeves
directing style turned out to be suited
for pattinson's acting techniques giving
him space to experiment i really like
the way matt directs in the kind of
super minutiae and like there's a lot of
takes pattinson has been open about the
struggles that came with taking on such
a beloved and iconic character while
still hoping to put a fresh spin on the
material it's now clear though that
reeves always knew how to help him
understand the role at one point after
doing over 40 takes for a scene
pattinson described himself as nearly
quote having an embolism and called it
his worst day on set however he also
said that the director still guided him
through it by showing him what was
working and what wasn't it's no surprise
that robert pattinson has figured out
how to get in tune with the director
pansin spent the decade after his
breakthrough role in twilight acting in
a series of projects with a plethora of
celebrated filmmakers from david
cronenberg to claire denis before the
batman pattinson coast arden christopher
nolan's long-delayed tenet alongside
john david washington in an interview
with entertainment weekly from 2020
nolan said having worked with rob i can
say with total confidence that he can do
absolutely anything he sets his mind to
and i could not be more excited to see
what he does with batman that's high
praise coming from the director of the
dark knight and belies the strong
working relationship the pair developed
on set of course professional
relationships cut both ways and it takes
a great director with the ability to use
their actors natural talents in order to
coax out a good performance even from a
seasoned pro like pattinson those who
have worked with matt reeves in the past
say he's exactly that kind of director
andy serkis starred as caesar the ape in
the recent planet of the apes trilogy
before being cast as alfred pennyworth
in the batman circus sang reeves praises
in an interview with collider saying no
matter what he touches everything is
considered it has intention it has
emotion it is powered by great
storytelling coming from circus whose
previous work has included everything
from lord of the rings trilogy to black
panther that sort of admiration means a
lot but circus didn't stop there saying
of reeves he is definitely one of the
greats and world-class directors that we
have at the moment
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]